et que des blagues en tête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais l'effondrement ça sonne comme la
fin du monde comme la bible mais là ça
c'est un récit juste c'est un récit
qu'on s'imagine pas c'est notre culture
etc on a vu aussi des films
hollywoodiens qui nous montre que
les apocalypses brutale biblique partie
ce que c'est notre imaginaire qui est
comme ça et tout l'enjeu justement de
l'accolade solo jc d'arriver à imaginer
d'autres récits d'autres manières de
voir l'effondrement et nous dans notre
livre comment tous effondrés ont décrit
vraiment c'est pas un événement brutal
c'est vraiment quelque chose de
graduelle des structures la société et
qui n'est pas déterminée non plus on
peut essayer de s'en relever
on peut essayer de d'en atténuer les
effets c'est quelque chose qui dure des
années voire des décennies
l' empire romain quand il s'effondre et
c'est quelque chose de l'ordre de 200
ans
[Musique]
alors oui il ya des effets vraiment
qu'on souhaite il ya des effondrements
qu'on souhaite pas par exemple moi je
souhaite pas l'effondrement des
populations d'oiseaux
des sols vivants des forêts etc ceci dit
s'il ya un effondrement du capitalisme
pourquoi pas et donc dans ses choix il
ya des effondrements ou souhaitent et
d'autres qui ne souhaite pas et c'est
des choix personnels
je pense qu'il ya des alliances ou à
faire et ça désigne ça dessine en tout
cas des chemins politiques
il ya des choix à faire et des chemins
politiques moi je souhaite plutôt un
effondrement en tout cas une
déstructuration narrait de cette méga
machines industrielles qui veulent
adhérer
je sais pas qui c'est mais j'imagine ce
sont des gens la télé réalité ou quelque
chose comme ça
effectivement la télé réalité je sais
pas si on peut parler d'un signes
d'effondrement peut-être de décadence je
sais pas en tout cas c'est pas quelque
chose je parle de la télé réalité j'ai
rien contre ces personnes mais c'est pas
quelque chose qui ouvre des horizons
beau possible et qui donne envie de
vivre l'avenir à nos enfants
il donne envie de rêver en tout cas pour
nos enfants
[Musique]
film culte bonne question moi je
parlerais plutôt d'une série que j'ai vu
il n'ya pas longtemps qu'ils s'appellent
d'une série anglaise hier à lierse
mini-série je crois qu'il y avait cinq
ou six épisodes d'humeur magnifique
série très réaliste qui montre sa part
du présent au royaume-uni et on voit les
deux trois quatre cinq prochaines années
qui glisser tranquillement vers le
ballon je fais pas de gâcher mais vers
une sorte de dégradation de la société
anglaise
[Musique]
cette année l'année prochaine dans les
mois qui viennent y'a vraiment des
risques de ruptures majeures
c'est pas parce que on a passé deux
vagues de penderie de covile
relativement bien et encore ça a été un
peu catastrophique mais bon on peut dit
concerné un peu tirés on n'a pas fini
encore de voir les conséquences et il
peut y avoir des conséquences très
graves
surtout au niveau politique géopolitique
derrière donc oui peut-être que les
mayas sont du reste du temps
[Musique]